God has given me strengthen and and the
attitude and I'm not suffering in any
way Valerie Harper has lost her battle
with cancer the last time ET spoke to
Valerie was in 2016 don't break ins it's
in the lining of the brain the actress
was diagnosed with lung cancer in 2009
four years later she was told the
disease was in her brain and she had
just three months to live I felt this
terrible feeling of numbness Tony my
husband thought I was having a stroke we
got to the hospital and they said oh you
have left oh meningeal carcinomatosis he
called it lepto for short because of the
law and it's in the lining of the brain
and it's been terrible and definitely
turn terminal 2 most doctors feel like
and it still is I mean I'm not cured or
not really in remission but my brain
scans darling have looked so much better
every six weeks I have one and the
cancer is going away it's responding to
the treatment that I've received
she claimed experimental treatment
allowed her to live well beyond
expectations I am NOT suffering I'm not
in pain so I'm really blessed I'm very
grateful I find something too something
many things to say thank you for every
day
with their smile
[Music]
TV audiences first got to know Valerie
in 1970 as Rhoda on The Mary Tyler Moore
Show and I'm Mary Richards hello get out
of my apartment
Valerie won four Emmys playing Mary's
brash neighbor who became her best
friend Mary I don't think this is you
well we're here let's look around we
might find something we like no kid
the flying bouncy knees wouldn't find
anything they like the success of the
show led to Valerie getting her own
spin-off Rhoda in 1987 Harper married
Tony Cottee nearly a decade after her
divorce from her first husband actor
Richard Shaw the to share one daughter
Cristina Harper you do go through grief
sorrow I don't want to die I'm having a
wonderful life why who would want to
leave Tony catch Ciotti
you